the bacteria in a petri dish culture are
self-duplicating at a rapid pace the
relationship between the elapsed time t
in minutes and the number of bacteria b
of t in the petri dish is modeled by the
following function and we see it's an
exponential model here how many bacteria
will make up the culture after
120 minutes
so really they just want to say well
what is b of 120 going to be and so it's
going to be 10
times 2
to the 120 divided by
12 power so this is going to be equal to
10 times 2 to the 120 divided by 12 is
power
so this is going to be equal to 10 times
2 to the 10th power is
1024. if you want to verify that you
could say well 2 to the fifth is equal
to 32 and so 2 to the 10th is going to
be 2 to the fifth times 2 to the fifth
and 32 times 32
is let's see 64 0
6 so let's see we're going to have 6
sorry 3 times 32 is
and so you have a 4 12
10 24.
so this is going to be 10 24 10 times
that is going to be equal to
1 0 2 4 0. so 10 200
ten thousand two hundred and forty
bacteria
and we're done